in five four three two one happy new
year I don't know when this is gonna
upload but still it's still a Happy New
Year
welcome to another episode of the genius
brain podcast I am your host David so
and I'm your other Thursday host Joe
Jitsu Kawa baby yes it's a new year
everybody has new year's goals I hope
you guys have been tackling them if not
then you're just like every other person
on this earth so don't [ __ ] worry
about everyone else that goes a [ __ ]
it's just another day yeah that's like
the what's that called in January where
everybody goes to the gym and for the
first three weeks and then around
February everybody disappears exactly
yep that's exactly what I do not any
different no you kept up with it dude
you had you met your goals last year I
know now I'm trying to drop like another
see if I'm to 15 right now 15 15 another
30 pounds so I want to be like 185 on a
good day just relaxing 185 190 and then
keep it there and then that's cruising
that's why I actually made the 90 days
to freedom program for weight loss but
it's it's it's mainly because people
don't follow through with what they want
because everyone just goes based off
motivation and inspiration yeah and it
never works Oh a hundred percent that
[ __ ] never [ __ ] works because it's
it's so it's fleeting you know I mean
like if you if you set this goal and you
do it based off of like I I call it the
the the Rocky movie syndrome when people
try to lose weight yeah you watched this
guy go through something and it inspires
you because every time I used to watch
the Rocky movie it would get me to want
to [ __ ] workout yeah sign up to a
boxing gym do all this other [ __ ]
but once that motivation disappears or I
stop thinking about the film my will to
work out or change myself disappears as
well yeah and that's exactly right like
I mean it's funny that you mentioned
that because it's what everyone does
right yeah they go here's my new year's
resolution I'm gonna freak and do this
right they get super inspired or
whatever like they might watch a TED
talk or whatever they get super inspired
they do it crazy for like a day or two
and then they stop doing it yeah and I
don't know I think for the
last year when I was doing Jamal Ian
Academy and I was creating all these
courses that's one thing that I realized
is people get hella motivated and then
they stop watching they stop doing the
work
we have about 17,000 students now yeah
for jemaldin Academy but a lot of them
because it's free I think what ends up
happening also is that they just kind of
lose focus there's no consequence that
there's no I don't know anything so I
had to kind of study like what's going
on with people because we're a little
bit different right so like me and you
like we're like a personal trainers
dream because they'll give us the work
then we do the work and we do the work
and we do more homework and we go
obsessed over what they teach us and
then we keep going harder and harder
yeah this is true between entrepreneurs
artists and and other people who are
self-sufficient or self-employed or they
own their own business right I don't
realize that this is a trait that we
came up with over time we weren't always
this way yeah and then so over the years
I'm sure you get this [ __ ] all the time
too the fans will be like hey man how do
you stay motivated
how do you stay inspired like how you
know how do you how do you get to where
you are and all that and I think like
the for the past 13 years like just
doing YouTube right I get that question
a lot
and I always answered it differently in
the very early stages it was like oh you
just gotta you know you just gotta like
stick with it bro like it's very
elementary right and then I think the
more I learn about myself the more my
answers start changing obviously like
later on it's like oh maybe it's not for
you maybe you just suck and then the
more I uncovered what was really going
on is people just got issues man yeah
and it's really about them it's not
really I mean the easiest thing is to
actually just do the work I think to
find the information people focus on the
wrong [ __ ] right you if you want to go
on Google now more than ever you can
just type in and say how do you start a
business how do you become a boxer how
there's a
information there's like unlimited
amounts of data to figure out what you
want to do so the hardest thing is not
information yeah that's what everyone
thinks oh I don't I don't know enough I
don't have knowledge I don't have this
information is not the hard part ideas
not the hard part access not the hard
part the hard part is self-control no
the hard part is isn't is is believing
in yourself the self-esteem then you
know self-awareness all this stuff so I
was like oh [ __ ] so the concept is
really it's it's really about letting go
all the [ __ ] and first and foremost
you got to believe in your own damn
dreams before you could even start and
that's where I was realizing is that
there's a lot of things that I missed
because I believe in my dreams first and
foremost if I want to do something like
for example even in your case right when
you're 16 you're like I want to be a
stand-up comedian that's something that
you said I'm gonna do and I'm a go for
mm-hmm cuz that was a dream that you
believed in a lot of people they want to
be a stand-up comedian but they don't
believe that they can do it yeah and I
was like so what brings a human to be
this way right and I'm like oh [ __ ] it's
because people don't know what they want
so the whole program is set up to be
where every single day you're given
basically like a task a small little
easy homework to do but it's repetition
because over the years people built up
this really bad habit of how they talk
to themself in their own minds yeah and
so if you're defeated and you fail
before you even start and you don't have
the right mentality no matter what you
apply yourself to do you're not gonna
finish it and you're not gonna kill it
yeah ravishing is is a big thing
especially like so for me I've helped a
few people lose weight and everybody has
this weight loss is so is so interesting
because there's so many different angles
that you could take in it just like any
kind of road to success right and one of
the biggest things that I've always
stated - especially like we have a
friend - and in Hawaii and you know she
was asking me about what's the things
that I should be eating what's this and
that I was like you know what [ __ ] it
before we even
do that I need to start I need you to
start building a habit yeah and that is
the hardest part for people to do
because it's the one that it requires
repetition constantly every single day
oh so what I've been getting her to do
is what I started and they're not
expecting like crazy results at first
but it's just to get into the habit of
doing something positive every day that
sets this pattern of positivity so for
her I told her all you need to do is
walk while every [ __ ] day because you
can walk every day you have that a bit
easy it's an easy thing to do but what
it does it not only teaches you to be
active when you first when you're first
losing weight but it also teaches you to
make activity a habit that you need in
your life and so that was like one of
the biggest things that I always told
people when they wanted to you know lose
weight at first is to just kind of set a
healthy habit first so what do most
people do they get super motivated they
go to the gym they workout for two hours
they're super sore and then they start
associating negative feelings because
it's too hard
mm-hm but it's we all been there right
we all binge work we all binge like like
went hard because we wanted results fast
or we think about how difficult it is
and then we think so much at a point
where we don't even step in the gym yeah
even in the same thing when it comes to
if you guys out there want to try script
writing write script writing I mean
there's a whole process to it and if
you've done the whole process you know
how to write a script from beginning
middle and end and you understand like
the back end parts a lot of people kind
of get stuck in the process of okay if I
write this then what happens in write a
page a day yeah write a page a day and
see what happened it's all that build
that habit little bit every day and so a
lot of people don't know how to do that
because I think what I realized is that
what if you've never really succeeded or
accomplished big right you don't know
how small baby steps is what creates the
big [ __ ] mm-hmm you just think big [ __ ]
and you compare yourself to other people
that's doing big [ __ ] and you're like oh
well I'm not Steven Spielberg so [ __ ]
mm-hmm and it's like but he has years
and years on you and you're comparing
yourself to the wrong people yeah like a
lot of people go oh well you know
chances are slim in
if I to being an athlete right like it
is it is a slim chance that's true from
where they're at
obviously like if you're not even in the
sport you know of course right yeah
but there's also a huge area from
different levels that you can make money
doing like you don't you could be in
dealey you could be a coach you could be
you know in the business you could work
like in sports somewhere you don't have
to be the athlete but there's so many
different levels to where you can be
making money in things that you enjoy
but they don't even think of that
because they go oh it's it's it's a low
percentage even our industry
entertainment Ellie's [ __ ] built on
that [ __ ] there's billions of dollars
right but what ends up happening is
people be like now there's no money in
entertainment yeah you can't get a job
it's like what are you [ __ ] talking
about like there's there's levels to
this I mean obviously there's people who
have you know acting is such a different
beast because there's a lot of people
who want to be actors and they they
shoot to be the actor who has the Oscar
who gets an Oscar who gets a Golden
Globe and they fall short of that but if
you really love what you're doing and
you're motivated behind it those things
are just like ancillary things right so
it's like you can fall into the category
of the the people beneath like that I
know a lot of supporting actors who I
really love who've never won a Golden
Globe yeah there's a lot of people who
make a living off of acting that aren't
recognized as you know like a Robert De
Niro or a Leonardo DiCaprio you know
there's a lot of other people like that
- yeah but to get your foot in a door
that's where I'm at like it's like a lot
of you know a lot of most people I'd say
is they don't even take the risk to get
their foot in the door hmm so that's my
whole thing right the whole concept of
90 days to freedom is you need to free
your mind first and foremost in order to
do whatever the [ __ ] you want in life if
you don't free your mind then you're
always gonna be trapped and you're
always gonna be feeling you know like in
your jail cell in your own in your own
head and I think that's the that's the
shittiest part because once we're able
to achieve and realize that there's a
way bigger world out there I'm just like
guys what the [ __ ] man it's not that
hard yeah that mental robe
definitely is something that I think a
lot of people can have help with because
I do see a lot of people who work in a
nine-to-five they kind of want to do I
just kind of control their own destiny
in terms of how much money they make or
what they're doing they don't they see
they could verbally say what they want
but when it comes to actually doing it
they kind of always fall short right
yeah and it's because like they don't
they almost can't and they kind of set
up these mental roadblocks for
themselves yeah like for example there's
a lot of people that I know that like
cooking
they love cooking cooking is their whole
life and then they go they look at a
huge restaurant that they enjoy they see
all the customers they see how busy it
is they immediately go like oh I can't
do this
yeah you know they fail before they
start out of people do that man and
there's a process to this and and if you
kind of take a step back to before these
restaurants were really big and we kind
of touched on this before they all
started somewhere man here's here's a
great example if you ever come out to
Los Angeles or if you're in Taiwan and
I'm pretty sure they're in other places
right now they're my favorite favorite
Xiao long bao place is Din Tai Fung man
they're worldwide now they're worldwide
now so didn't I funnel originally was
this small little shack if you go to the
original Din Tai Fung spot it's like
five or six stories yeah don't quote me
on that but it's a lot of stories I've
been to that yes right
that place was one story at first it
grew to be second stories look the whole
file ding yeah and so if they stacked it
they just kept growing it on top that's
why you see those tight stairs so they
just kept building acted like their
dumpling exactly like a dumpling steam
basket but that was a mom-and-pop shop
at first if somebody told them when they
first started that hey you are going to
be this standard for what a delicious
dumpling is gonna be a Xiao long bao
yeah everybody's gonna talk about you
people are gonna travel worldwide just
to go to your place I guarantee you they
would have said impossible right
so everybody starts somewhere right but
you're looking at the end goal and
you're seeing something that's so hard
for you to manage because of where
you're at right now well it's gonna take
time and steps to eventually get there
even for us we started off with one I
started off with this small little
soft-serve yogurt shop I took those life
lessons brought
over to a different business that he and
I worked on together with a bunch of our
friends and then we kept growing and
growing growing it's been three years it
takes time one dumpling at a time one
[ __ ] dumpling at a time and that's
the whole baby-step concept right that I
think it gets overwhelming because they
see the star that's you know the
oscar-winning [ __ ] actor or they see
the businessman
that's a Multi [ __ ] billionaire or
whatever like they see you know the top
top and it's like whoa man that seems
really hard which it is but there's a
whole different level to it and I mean
like everything does start from
completely nothing and from scratch and
that's where we go on to the whole thing
of like there's a three-step process to
this and I broke it down to 90 days
because it takes 90 days to make a habit
really ingrained in your system just
psychologically that's how it works if
you do something every day for 90 days
you know it becomes a part of you
another thing is if you're listening to
positive things every single day that's
something that's really important
because most people they don't have a
positive influence no one around them
and in their own mind is saying anything
positive most people especially if
you're [ __ ] Asian your guys are
talking [ __ ] to you every single day
yeah and it's really important because
if you if you're constantly being told
that you're a dumbass or whatever and
you tell that self to yourself then you
manifest that thought you become a
[ __ ] dumbass even if you're not yeah
so the first step is basically
identifying what the hell you want like
do you want to lose weight do you want
to make a million dollars do you want to
be a musician a lot of people can't even
do that a lot of people don't even know
what their passion is and it's because
they fail before they start it just
keeps going back to that it's like they
get there like they go oh you know it
would be so cool if I did stand-up
comedy like David but I can't so they go
they have that but and they go oh but I
can't or but there's too many people or
there's so many youtubers already I
can't do it is saturated there's an
excuse right but then we have
we have to identify it and confront it
because if you don't confront those
excuses then you'll never get what you
want people will always go oh you know I
want to be I want to make a million
dollars but that's for rich people you
had to be born rich or whatever right so
you have to you have to identify it and
then number two is we have to remove
those limiting beliefs yeah cuz if
you're [ __ ] always limiting yourself
and you don't realize that you have this
habit of consistently creating excuses
limits whatever it is then it has you
has to go you have to go through the
conditioning of remembering why not you
should be doing this [ __ ] and you should
be creating new belief system and then
finally the first third step is starting
to get into the action plans yeah
because what people fail to do is they
go straight into the action and then
they don't have the right mentality to
support the action yeah same with the
going back to the fitness thing right
everyone gets all like I'm gonna go work
out
it's January first inspired but their
mind isn't right so they'll do the
physical action they'll get the personal
trainer but they're not gonna stick with
it you know
so I think this is the whole system that
I created and I also want people to
[ __ ] stick with this [ __ ] too so what
I also said to everyone is that if after
the program it still doesn't work for
them I'm giving them a hundred percent
money back yeah because I want it to
work or else it's like there's no value
here's the interesting thing though and
I think I really want people to get this
part too is that let's say you do this
program right which let's say you tried
something out in this program you you
think you allocated something that you
really wanted to do and then it turns
out that it's not what you wanted to do
that actually happened a lot oh yeah the
difference is is that kind of setting up
a habit to really achieve a goal is
really what you're learning here it's
like you did the steps and you figured
out what you thought you liked and
things change all the [ __ ] time
that's what people also have to
understand even if you build a positive
habit
which number one is the first step and
this is what I truly believe if you
build a positive habit and you really do
believe that you can make something
happen and you do the due diligence to
make sure that it does and you kind of
get there you might find out that that's
not what you want but that's just a part
of life the cool thing is you you just
learned all the right tools to do it
again and then to really figure out what
your next step is mm-hmm so for me just
to give you an example I thought I
wanted to be the biggest stand-up comic
in the world turns out that that wasn't
it I don't even like to his den F
anymore you know but from all that work
you learned so much exactly them from
that that that type of hustle that type
of grind and kind of doing all these
stand-up shows over and over and over I
was like okay cool what do I want to do
guess what I want to I want to make a
film did the same type of hustles the
same type of steps and that same type of
dedication that I had before and the
belief that I can make a film and do it
really well
mm-hmm then Sundance happened then we
sold the film cool did that I wanted to
then I took that same puzzle got signed
to an agency which I got removed from
now because I'm not acting anymore they
were not too happy with me they're like
well aren't you going out on these
auditions like could your [ __ ]
audition that you send me are trash
anyways I started to stop doing that and
then it was then it was like okay I want
to do food you know worked with Tim we
we sold the the the the send foods the
Thrillist
yeah and then that was cool then was
like cool well I want to take this food
thing another step and then I worked on
this Netflix thing yeah and it's the
same process in the application just
exact goals and it's pretty [ __ ] dope
that I know that if I set my mind to
something no matter whatever the time
span is if I really truly want it I'm
gonna go and [ __ ] get it it's going
to [ __ ] happen and that's the
mentality that people need to have is
the self belief yeah and you have that
and that's one of the things that I
realized was missing in so many people
mmm is that ability to say you know what
all it takes is for me to learn this
[ __ ] and I'm gonna get it yeah but
that's built over time because you had
these little wins and you've proven to
yourself that whatever idea you have you
could make it come to life yeah it you
know little wind is a really good thing
too because I think sometimes too
people think that maybe this application
only works for a large goal it could
work for something small like I when I
was younger too I remember I wanted to
be a musician that was the original
dream before comedy and the small goals
that I made for myself was to do live
shows you know whatever Cafe spot was
open I would go out there grab my guitar
set it up started singing whatever that
was a small goal and then I wanted to
save up to save this this is a brand
called seagull it was a guitar that I
really liked and I worked a particle
stick acoustic so I work two part-time
jobs I worked worked my ass off to get
this guitar and it was used when I
bought it by the way but that was those
small wins that kind of boosted me that
was like yeah I got this [ __ ] guitar
now I can perform better it has a dope
preamp in it now I get to do these live
shows and I took these small victories
reapplied at small victories small
victory small big three big victory yeah
and it's all those baby steps man those
little wins add up to a big win but if
you don't go and start in the first
place you don't even get to experience
the wins and another thing that people
do I realized is that they don't even
recognize their wins yeah yeah you don't
recognize their accomplishments and I
think especially in the Asian community
too we're growing up we're raised to
grow up without ego right or like well
they try to keep us down with staying
humble humble like I quote that because
it's it's really not the truth they just
don't want us to brag or say anything
but it turns into this thing where
you're not supposed to recognize your
accomplishments that's the biggest thing
that I think is the well there's a lot
of difference between me and Tim but Tim
is somebody who does that really well
Tim does it for himself too you want to
talk about positivity and really
manifesting your destiny like Timothy
DeLaGhetto does that really really well
he even does something too even
something small like I remember I was
reading on his Twitter or was it
Instagram but he looked back at 2019 and
I said this is what I did this year I
sold my own TV show I did MTV's basic to
bougie I did through a list
I sold a show to Thrillist I did this
this and that did in my own film
blah-blah-blah-blah-blah now whether
people look at that as a huge
accomplishment or not he he does a
checklist of stuff that he's proud of
that he that he did and he makes sure
that he reaffirms it in positivity he
goes these this is this is what I've
done and I don't even do that for myself
I say it's not good enough yeah I always
do that to myself which is why it's hard
for me sometimes to grow did you grow up
with your parents telling you that yeah
I think so first I did yeah sure sure my
dad looked at it and goes that's it you
think that's a win yeah and then he's
like nah you that's not you you can't
you can't be okay with that you got to
keep going you got to be perfect that's
what was drilled into me that's not
perfect yeah perfection is what we
strive for that's the hard part to it
some and when when it comes to creating
content is always expecting perfection
and the I think it was if you guys know
like like Mark Duplass like he he always
says if you like it this is for
filmmakers out there he always goes if
you have a friend you have a camera you
can make a film like there's always
that's true you don't have to nothing
has to be perfect before you put it out
there yeah like you you're not the first
thing that you do is never going to be
perfect and it's when you look back at
it you're gonna hate I hate every single
one of my videos that I put out and
severed this one video that I did where
I parried in a Wong foo video like I
look at that and it cracks me up yeah I
mean and there's another video where I
did like this where I made it in an out
burger there's like a few videos where I
look back and I'm like this there's
nothing I would have done different yeah
but it's not like that and that's like I
have like maybe 10 videos out of like
thousands that I say that about mm-hmm
nothing else though and it's it's just
nothing's ever going to be perfect you
just have to try yeah yeah so I mean
when when you develop this program where
you kind of like were you what do you do
you kind of develop it based on like the
previous mistakes that you've done
before when you were younger and then a
lot of people again yeah a lot of it is
just based off of trial and error and I
always had this desire to basically be
involved in our fans like group like on
our fans self-development right and then
because I get these questions all the
time like yeah how do I do this how do I
do
that and so I always I think that's
always been a passion of mine right cuz
just kidding films we all started with
the catchphrase with the with the with
the model of teaching good things in the
bad way so all of our content was
teaching and I always felt fulfillment
whenever I learned something I put it in
a skit or an art form or whatever and
then it can give something hmm but now
it's more in-your-face it's a straight
up step by step and yeah I wish someone
told me this [ __ ] when I was younger now
that I'm 35 before I didn't feel like I
had an authority or I had the right to
even say anything but now I'm like man
I've been on YouTube for over ten years
I've been running my own businesses like
my whole life has been just making money
off a fun [ __ ] yeah not only that like
we're crushing it and as friends as like
you know finding that recipe for a good
loving environment with friends and
everything just making money together
business even in hobbies right like I
was never a thick and Here I am like
doing athletic [ __ ] yeah
and I'm like you know what there is a
recipe to this stuff yeah and I just
want to go out there and kind of share
it especially with the people that have
been supporting and watching us for a
long time I think it's really important
for them yeah that's interesting to them
when you mentioned how important it is
to hear somebody say good job to you as
you grow up because we've touched on
this before where we mentioned how the
things that you experienced when you're
younger you don't realize the ripple
effect it has on you as an adult yeah
way [ __ ] late Oh big time dude
because I that I work hard not for
myself it's it's it's more like it's not
even for my audience it's more like this
false sense of parents that I'm fighting
for but I don't give a [ __ ] what they
think yeah it's just like it's almost
like let's say like you're conditioned
because you have this abuser but even if
the abusers gone you still used to that
habit
right so the number one thing in this
overall program is if you don't have
self love you don't have freedom yet
doing things for yourself is a huge
thing because for me I felt like one of
my biggest motivating factors for a lot
of the major accomplishments that I've
had in my life were was always to say
[ __ ] you to somebody who didn't believe
I could do something yeah so you're
you're seeking approval right exists not
for you and then what the the huge
pitfall in that that I found out was
after you have done your [ __ ] you to
somebody and you accomplished it you're
left with nothing
yeah your where's your enemy if you
constantly fighting and you need an
enemy right one you know when you don't
have one where's your motivation now
it's nowhere to be found yeah and that's
kind of like the thing that as of right
now that I'm trying to get out of
because a lot of the stuff that I've
done has been a big [ __ ] you know a lot
of people like I was told I couldn't be
a stand-up comic so I was like okay
let's see about that it was like my
parents said I couldn't do it I had a
few people that I knew that went to a
couple of my stand-up shows it wasn't
that great but I just started and I was
like [ __ ] you and then I did it I took
my comedy somewhere I did shows 500
thousands of people did multiple time
did four years in a row and then after a
while I was like wait what am I doing
this for
I even like stand-up I think I just did
it just to say [ __ ] you to somebody and
then now that person it's like on my
side saying I'm proud of you it's like
nothing I know even the film that I did
was because I couldn't get an audition I
couldn't get an agency to sign me
because they thought I was just an
influencer I didn't have talent and I
was like okay well let me make my own
film there and now that they want you
you're like not auditioning process and
then my motivation for acting isn't like
how it used to be yeah because I've I
based it off of proving somebody wrong
and just saying [ __ ] you this is
imaginary thing that doesn't [ __ ]
exist and once you've done it you've
done your [ __ ] use you've done all that
and now it's like okay
I didn't do it for myself now what the
[ __ ] am i left with it this is it it's
it's a well that depletes yeah
you know and that's one of the things
that we talked about in the program is
like all these eggs like all the years
of
doing this in experiencing burnout or
doing things for the wrong reason maybe
right I'm preventing them from making
the same mistake or look out for it yeah
because you know people accomplish great
things motivated by the wrong things
like you don't mean like like there are
people who become [ __ ]
multimillionaires just constantly
seeking approval they become super
famous because there's narcissists and
they want everything you know they're
constantly looking for validation we
know some youtubers that are like
they're just constantly looking at that
[ __ ] subscriber number yeah and as
soon as it goes down and up they freak
out you know like it's a weird thing to
let something that it's hard for people
to really understand that concept of you
don't need it this podcast is brought to
you by purple baby a purple mattress
sis's are the best they caress your body
like a lovely lovely person's touch and
hugs your spirit soul and back like
nothing ever before I used to have a lot
of back pain I used to have a lot of
trouble sleeping but my sleep sleep
sleep has been so much better since the
purple mattress has entered my life I'm
talking about his firm I'm talking about
its soft and I'm also saying that it
keeps me cool at night which is
everything that I need in a mattress if
you're sleeping on something super hard
because some Asian grandmother told you
that you had to sleep on a rock for your
back they lied and that's why their back
hurts well you don't need back pain and
you don't need that type of Asian
grandma advice well you need is a purple
mattress it feels amazing check it out
by the way 100 night risk-free trial if
you're not fully satisfied you can
return the mattress for a full refund
backed by a 10-year warranty free
shipping and returns you're going to
love purple and right now my listeners
will get a free purple pillow with the
purchase of a mattress that's in
addition to the great free gifts they're
offering site-wide just takes brain to
eight four - eight eight eight the only
way to get this free pillow is the text
brain - eight four - eight eight eight
that's B R a I n - eight four eight
eight eight you know what I mean yeah so
when I when I tell somebody who's young
actually I won't even say young or
anybody on social media they go they
look at their numbers and ad window
this is these are people who aren't
really making a living off of it but
they're so obsessed with being
recognized
having somebody place a value on who
they are as a person instead of doing
that for yourself right because those
numbers actually mean I'm worth
something yeah that's the hard part
right and I don't know how to tell
somebody now where it's like you know
you don't have to have an Instagram
right yeah your existence what you do
all the important things in your life
your family everybody who loves you your
importance is still there without the
whole world knowing that knows that you
exist yeah that's something that's very
odd in this world it's like I there's
there's a friend of mine now that I
almost want to call this dude up and be
like bro you need a delete Instagram
because I see his terrible terrible
behaviors of him constantly seeking
approval and if he doesn't get the right
approval deletes his post it's like how
are you how are you living like this
dude and it [ __ ] him up I could see it
[ __ ] him up yeah when it when he has a
bad day or something is going on in his
life he has to put post the most
dramatic things just to see if people
react it's like today is like one of
those days where I really felt like I
was gonna kill myself which those
feelings are valid but for you to put it
out in the public platform when you know
you have friends like me you have other
people that could help you and talk
about it makes me feel like this isn't
really real this is more you wants
attention you want attention so like for
example like when he posted that message
then I'll say hey bro are you okay no
I'm fine
and I'm not are you but how come you
posted that thing that's like ah you
know like I was just feeling sad I was
like bro if you're feeling just sad
don't say you're gonna kill yourself it
freaks me the [ __ ] out yeah yeah you
know what I mean and that's when I was
like are you what the [ __ ] are you doing
right now you know those are the people
that I worry about because they're so
glued to this identity of like what of
me being important based on this [ __ ]
digit on this [ __ ] app yeah it's
terrible yeah and that's because a lot
of people are just empty they're looking
for validation they're looking for
significance and I mean that's the whole
concept of this whole 90 days freedom is
that a lot of people aren't free if
you're if you're tied to something and
you're and and you you need to you need
find value through just Instagram or
like
other [ __ ] empty reasons you're not
free as a human being that's just not
the definition of freedom it's kind of
cool because I feel like your your
program can help people in a lot of ways
like I I feel like when it first started
it seems like the program can be
applicable to people who are looking for
financial freedom or just like career
freedom but it also could just be like
you as a person just that that feeling
of really believing you have options and
choices that's the secret
actually yeah so people come in and
they're like I want to pursue my passion
I want to make money off of my dreams or
whatever that's the hook right but where
I get them is I actually help people
become a strong individual mentally and
all that stuff will help everything else
right that's great because that's this
that's the real secret behind all of
this right yeah is whenever we go to
colleges and [ __ ] and we do the q and
A's a lot of people ask like what's the
secret to business what's to seek what's
the hardest things you have to deal with
all that and I said yourself and your
emotions the hardest [ __ ] is never like
coming up with the best product whatever
like it gets hard but me and you both
know the people part and your personal
part is the most hardest [ __ ] yeah
dealing with other people and dealing
with how you react to other people the
emotional stress the problems the drama
the you yourself your ego being okay
when you put your heart and soul into an
invention and and your partner saying
nah that's not cool it sucks how do you
deal with that they don't teach you that
[ __ ] yeah man dude I [ __ ] emotional
like controlling your emotions and kind
of really controlling the stuff that you
know that are within your control is the
hard part to recognize yeah because
everything feels like chaos sometimes
right yeah and like for example I was at
one Mary oh and I first started going
out and I'm guilty of this too but
because I'm guilty of it I could also
recognize it in somebody like Muriel
who's my partner so one of the things
that she used to do when we first
started going on that I didn't like was
that she's a coordinator so as a
coordinator I believe mentally
she likes to block things off in
segments and make sure things are within
her control so these things should
happen at this time if it doesn't happen
at this time it's a big deal yeah what I
was trying to get her to realize when we
were first going out was when things are
out of your control things are just out
of your control no matter how angry you
get no matter how mad you get no matter
how much you cry it doesn't change the
fact that the result is gonna be the
same so you just have to recognize that
so there was this one time where this
was kind of like my last straw with it I
actually picked her up to go to the
airport and when we were going to there
up where we left super early but there's
construction on the freeway
she starts freaking the [ __ ] out right
she goes I'm gonna be late blah blah
blah what if I miss his flight I was
like listen if you miss you you miss it
if you miss it you miss it you know look
the next one whatever how much you yell
at me no matter how much you cry at this
point because you're scared those people
that are doing their [ __ ] on the freeway
they're not gonna do it faster for you
we're stuck in this situation and that's
what it is the more you freak out about
it the more I get angry the more you get
frustrated yeah you only do yourself a
disservice right but people are people
and they're emotional creatures yeah but
that's the thing is like if you want to
become successful if you want to win at
life and you want to do a lot of that
stuff that's the number one thing you
got to control is yourself in your mind
and that's what people don't get and I'm
like it's right in front of your faces
like why do you think it's the
environment why do you think it's the
product why do you think it's the
business all these external forces knots
you and I think that's the hardest thing
is people cannot take responsibility and
for the longest time I think I had that
problem as well even while I'm going
through this phase where people think
I'm successful or whatever it's like I
could have been even more if I figured
this [ __ ] out earlier yeah yeah
damn dude 90 days to freedom baby um you
know it's kind of cool like I I do
appreciate the fact that we can um I
think I think we should console echt the
best parts of what we've learned yeah
and then put it somewhere where people
can really apply it and hopefully they
can learn from it if not then you know
it is what it is that's why this you
guys can get your money back but it's
it's it's cool like I think this is the
paying afford type of thing that's real
important in life which I really like
I'd like when you could pay it forward
to somebody it's really I mean it's
really gratifying we're only on day
three right now
and so another piece of this is you get
access to a private group on Facebook
that's awesome other students who are
doing it because I think the number one
most important thing is the support that
we're all missing right it's like if you
if you if you had support early on in
life to pursuing whatever the [ __ ] you
wanted - emotional support community
support you probably make it way quicker
yeah for sure I mean that was one of the
biggest fights that I actually had with
my dad was like I think I think when I
said this to him when we got into he
this was our last really big fight and
it was like four or five years ago and
that's the last time I actually got into
a fight with them was because I think I
said something very pointed to him that
kind of hurt his feelings a lot which
was he kind of just look as a parent you
you don't know what you're doing
they hid no matter how many books you
read no matter what people do people say
to you that is the right way of
parenting you know I think all of us as
humans we can only take from what we
learned and try to do better than what
our parents did for us right and that's
what my dad's I wouldn't want to say
excuse but that was his reasoning behind
him being so hard on me and that was
also his reasoning to justify all the
[ __ ] that things he did right yeah
because in his mind and what we happens
when we were yelling at each other he
was like you know I I did the best that
I could you know but he wasn't really
listening to me and saying that yeah I
get you did the best that you could he
still doesn't mean that you didn't [ __ ]
up in the parse that yeah he's just
trying to deny any fault it's like you
you could have just said good job to me
once in my life I would have really
appreciated it and it's funny because I
remember this one time and this is prior
to this fight is when I was super young
girl we got into a huge fight and I
remember I looked at him I was like how
come you can't just say good job like I
it was when I first of all I left
Riverside I hated going there which is a
whole nother story which I'm pretty sure
you guys heard before but we're not
gonna get into that came back and I went
to Community College and when I came to
Community College this was a during a
time that I really wanted to figure out
if I could be
good student right well I had to go to
summer school to make up a lot of
credits that I didn't get in UCR because
I failed a lot of classes but during
summer school I got straight A's
hmm and I was hyped and this is it goes
back to that thought of me I wasn't
doing getting those straight A's for
myself I did it to show my dad that I
was a smart kid mm-hmm you know and I
remember I was super hyped and I was
like what 20 at the time and I was like
hey I got straight A's at us at three
subjects that I [ __ ] hate yeah so you
know I went and remember I saw my mom
say hey I got straight A's like summer
school is over and my mom was like oh
yeah awesome good job right but I wasn't
I know she was gonna say it but I wanted
him to say it he goes cool you did what
you're supposed to do I was like cool
yes yeah you know that's yeah I was like
[ __ ] you know and I remember like I was
pissed about it all day I was mad I was
holding it in and then yeah I kind of
mentioned it like yeah I worked really
hard and I got that a you know as I did
I do a good job right yeah honey it was
I he goes he goes you see that just
proves that you're lazy and I was like
damn [ __ ] man and I remember I got
pissed I looked at him else like why
can't you just say good job yeah why is
this so hard for you say good [ __ ]
job like this is not something that was
indicative of what I've done when I was
younger when I was in high school
terrible [ __ ] grades until the last
my the last semester of my junior year
and then my senior year I got like
straight A's and I did that just so
hopefully I can get into college and I
did with a 2.6 GPA was the bare minimum
cut off to get into a university and I
got into [ __ ] you see [ __ ] side
which is Riverside and then so you know
doing that and just wanting that a
little bit of affirmation and just to
grow up in that positive environment
would have really helped it would have
you know it would have helped my comedy
to it would have helped a lot less
instead of like telling me that comedy
was dumb and I you know he should know
my personality I'm his son like if I set
my mind to something I'm a [ __ ] do it
yeah it's the balance and imagine if I
mean you had that positive support and
love in that way I feel like half the
battles already gone mm-hmm you don't
have to deal with so much so for me it's
like maybe you can't get that from your
family but if you're fighting the fight
with other people that are trying to
better themselves other people that are
trying
to go through this program and [ __ ]
kill it at life you have access to that
so we have close to thousand people
right now that are just active helping
each other out it's such a [ __ ] loving
community it's like man and I'm in there
a lot too so along with the with the
program I think there's the community
aspect of it and the support and I think
it's hard to do things on your own so
you're in your doing the program by
yourself I think there's probably gonna
be drop-off yeah but the goal for me is
everyone to stick through this [ __ ] and
at the end we're gonna do a live event
awesome yeah that's dope
we're gonna get everybody in LA people
can come in from wherever they want to
be wherever they're from they can come
in and we're gonna do like a live like
graduation kind of thing for everyone
that finished but they do have to do the
work because I know some people just buy
the [ __ ] product so they can come to
the event so you can't cheat the system
you got to do the work you got to watch
the videos and then at the very end of
it all you know we're gonna celebrate
together we're gonna I think it's gonna
be [ __ ] cool and then people get to
meet the people that they've been
communicating with and making friends
with so I think that's the whole key is
like when you create a support and
community and a group of friends I'm
trying to replicate what we have for JK
and our friendship yeah you know
positive like-minded people that can be
like family but through this program
that's dope yeah 90 days to freedom baby
yep you know I hope this this podcast
actually helped out a lot of people I
mean obviously it's just kind of like
the tip of the iceberg in terms of cuz a
lot of this stuff is just like quick
stories and knowledge and you know
having a package in a different way
could probably help you out but this is
really where it all starts you know and
it's interesting too because I think
that you know we did mention that
there's a lot of we mentioned earlier
that there's a lot of knowledge out
there but it's how you use that
knowledge and package it is the hard
part right because for example we could
say hey how come you don't know how to
cook
it's
like there's cooking videos online
there's a reason why people can't do it
even though all that knowledge is there
yeah there's something blocking them
yeah there's something that's missing
there's some there's some type of like
instructional there's some type of like
feel something something that's not
there that helps you kind of get to that
point and I get it too because and yet
it just goes back to just really
experiencing things and repetition over
and over and over when I when I first
started cooking I suck dick at it I I
remember the first dish that I made was
lasagna and I made that lasagna from
watching all the the PBS like free stuff
and I tried making it and that [ __ ]
tastes like hot ass yeah it was
disgusting but after repetition and
doing it over and over again and really
gaining experience I I make a pretty
decent lasagna yeah I'm saying I could
be a little Super Mario Italian now she
I think cooking is fun cooking is my
managed experiences it's a lot it's a
lot of like trying things out and
failing and I think like the hard part
about cooking is when you're left with
this pile of food then nobody wants to
eat and it's dishes oh and the [ __ ]
dishes man but now it's like now I'm
like pretty comfortable if I try a dish
enough that I could probably replicate
it mm-hmm
listen recently I you know I was doing
like shoyu ramen and stuff I [ __ ] for
I hate fake [ __ ] making ramen noodles
- by the way ramen noodles are [ __ ]
you make the noodles from scratch yeah
it's annoying oh my god and it's not as
good as the [ __ ] that I get it you know
what I buy it so it's like I mean I'm
gonna say it's not as good but if it's
not better why make it yeah you got to
make the handmade noodles like yeah the
right way or something exactly I don't
know what it is but everybody has their
own recipes but like I just decided to
just buy the noodles and just do the the
long arduous process to make a really
really good broth and then yeah so like
I've liked that whole process was really
fun but [ __ ] it's annoying yeah well
guys that wraps up this genius brain
podcast for your guys's new year's goals
or just like any general goals you all
have to start somewhere man
I had a weight loss Gold New Year's goal
went out in 2010 at 2,000 dead and it
took like in eight years to get there so
we all got to start somewhere start with
positivity and then check out 90 days to
freedom yes yeah well what else can they
expect in the the program
pretty much by the end of the program
you are pretty much you have your foot
in the door and you're in the field that
you always wanted to be in or you're in
the hobby that you're always you know
you always wanted to do and all the
things that you pretty much set yourself
out to you have a stronger belief in
yourself and a stronger idea of all the
things that you dreamed of and and
you're more honest with your goals Oh
awesome
well guys you can catch the genius brain
podcast on all audio platforms if you
have if there's a rating system on there
give us that five star Beibei and leave
in the comments below about topics that
you want us to talk about if you guys
want priority on those topics you don't
know there's a patreon for that so we
will see you all next time baby please
wait